[Applause]
every year the American Israel Public
Affairs Committee or APEC hosts a huge
conference in the nation's capital
almost 20,000 people in the audience a
highly polished production on stage the
focus always the speakers many of whom
are Washington's most powerful
politicians both Democratic and
Republican they show up and it shows
AIPAC is a political force and there
will be powerful Democrats there with
one very notable exception I am very
proud to be Jewish and look forward to
being the first Jewish president
misfunction Democratic presidential
frontrunner senator Bernie Sanders is
not only refusing to go he's slamming
the organization on Twitter writing I
remain concerned about the platform APEC
provides for leaders who express bigotry
and oppose basic Palestinian rights APEC
responded tweeting back in part that it
was quote in a rageous comment about
what they labeled a mainstream
bipartisan event but American University
professor guys've believes support for
Israel in the u.s. is becoming a
partisan issue and Netanyahu has a big
role to play here because he in 2012
invited Mitt Romney during the
presidential election to Israel and
hosted him as a way to endorse him over
Obama a few years later in 2015 in March
definitely Iowa comes here and delivers
that speech to a joint session of
Congress in which he tried to scuttle
the Iran nuclear deal which was the
president's signature foreign policy
achievement and to some it seems even
more so now given the close ties between
the current Republican president Donald
Trump and Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu
the divide was on full display with this
television at Bernie's a great guy but
he just can't run by a group of
prominent Democratic supporters of
Israel openly campaigning against
Sanders who could become the first
Jewish nominee from a major party the
ads stopped when he became the
front-runner and it's who he appeals to
that could be the greatest concern over
the long term
he's garnering the most support among
young people who were well aware of this
issue and his concerns although Nadine
Epstein editor-in-chief of moment
magazine a publication focused on
American Jews says that fear of turning
young people could be overblown I see a
lot of young people are very interested
in Warren and then don't forget there
were a lot of conservative young people
and I see a lot of people talking about
young people talking about Klobuchar I
see them talking about Bloomberg most
analysts say over the long term if APEC
is going to keep the kind of influence
it needs to have bipartisan support
trying to strike a balance this year
with elections looming in both countries
will be more of a challenge than ever
before pedicle hain al Jazeera
Washington